welcome back everybody we're wrapping up
our fitness week on good day las vegas
with some
tips and tricks from experts and we're
in the kitchen with paul rosenberg good
morning nice to have you here
paul's the author of real nutrition and
he's the owner of real
real results fitness and i understand
you've gotten a lot of results from the
people who've worked with you
and that you've worked with them on
their nutrition plan and their workout
plan
you've written a book and we're going to
get a little taste of some of your
nutrition plan
and get some great tips from you thanks
for being with us this morning
so what is your top nutrition tip really
through your 12 12 week nutrition
challenge
well when it comes to losing body fat or
getting in shape the most important
thing is commitment and people think
that it might be about the diet and what
you're consuming but ultimately
it's going to boil down to your state of
mind so if you're really committed
even if you make a mistake you're going
to stay on track so what you're doing
as far as the big picture is what's
going to produce the results
rather than if you screw up here and
there okay so as long as you know
what your end goal is and and you help
people do that
yes we we have uh with our book
we also um this is a structured program
but
what's good about it is that we hold
people accountable
so ultimately you know people have to
hold themselves accountable
and that's where they're going to make
great progress but if they have a coach
that's
guiding them and steering them
throughout the 12 weeks it's a lot
easier for them to stay on track
okay so workout is always important but
nutrition
too and do you call it eating clean or
or what do you call the nutrition plan
well it's it's just it's mostly a
challenge
which is meant to uh you know bring
about the best in you but
yes if you have the structure if you
have the accountability then that's
going to help you to stay on track the
whole time
and we have our clients log their food
so writing down your food is proven to
be one of the best things to do
to stay on track when it's staring you
in the face then you know what you're
you don't forget what you're eating yes
but it also keeps what you're eating top
of mind all the time
okay so you stay focused on it and then
the trainer is holding you accountable
because they're checking your food log
all the time all right so that it can
guide you and steer you throughout the
process
you've got a lot of good foods out here
some stuff i recognize some stuff i
don't recognize
and you're gonna make us a shake this
morning is that right yes i have a
healthy smoothie
and we've got all these ingredients you
know like cacao
these are some of the items that i would
put in a smoothie i love this
oat milk i've recently found that
previously i was using almond milk but
oat milk is fantastic i talked a lot
about oat milk we've got two different
proteins three different protein powders
that we can choose from
okay but most of this is plant-based so
it digests very easily
which helps to speed up the metabolism
and it's very light also so it's not
like it's going to make you feel
weighted down does it taste good
can i taste it absolutely what okay what
kind of shake is this
this is a smoothie that has pretty much
a a number of these ingredients in here
okay so veggies swiss chard cabbage
carrots spinach and these powders which
i
prepare in advance and then i can just
very easily make my smoothie by pouring
it in there okay so the smoothie only
takes a minute
okay that's pretty easy
but it's quite quite tasty it is oh it's
very thick
i heard it would turn my teeth green so
i said i'll try it with a spoon if you
don't have a straw
mmm not bad right that's really good now
looking at it it might not look
appealing but it is it's really
delicious what's the name of your book
and how can people get that book to get
on your nutrition challenge
this uh the book is called real
nutrition and if they go to our website
which is real resultsfitness.com
there's a section on there which is by
the book and we also have it on amazon
so people can buy it on amazon by
looking up real nutrition
and and you'll recognize it by how good
the food looks on the cover oh thank you
all right thanks so much paul we're
going to come back with you in the next
half hour
because eating right during extreme heat
like we have here in our las vegas
summers
is also very important so your body
doesn't bog you down because
it's hard enough to get through extra
hot days so we're going to talk about
that when we come back in the next half
hour okay we appreciate you being here
we'll see you in a just a few minutes